avec le lancement de la nouvelle renault
clio iv et de la zoé la voiture
électrique de la marque
le rendement de l'usiné de flins
augmente mais les salariés sont
confrontés à un manque d'effectifs selon
les syndicats présents aux portes du
centre ce jeudi midi
on est en colère parce que il faut si on
veut fabriquer correctement des voitures
il faut du personnel et entre les gars
qui morfle sur les chaînes etc
d'un côté et ceux qui morfle du chômage
à côté c'est inadmissible et du coup ça
s'est exprimée vraiment par des arrêts
de travail ce matin pour contraindre la
direction à prendre l'effectif suffisant
encore ce matin yves une heure et demi
d'arrêt de travail des caristes pour
réclamer du personnel supplémentaire
parce que ils n'arrivent pas à décharger
les camions ils n'arrivent pas à mettre
les pièces là où il faut et c'est les
salariés de renault flins se rendront
mardi 9 octobre pour manifester au
mondial de l'automobile
avant de se joindre à un cortège
nationale à l'appel des syndicats
européens